مهما كانت النتيجة،
إذا نجحت إسرائيل بالفعل وقامت
بتطهير الشعب الفلسطيني عرقيًا، فسوف يخسرون لأننا
لن ننسى أبدًا هذا الأمر ولن نسمح
لإسرائيل أبدًا بأن تكون ضحية في
هذه القصة عندما يريد الناس
إعادة سردها يومًا ما، سأتأكد من ذلك.  أن
يعرف أطفالي ما حدث،
سأتأكد من أن أطفالي يعرفون أن إسرائيل
دولة إرهابية وأي شخص يدعمها
ويدعمها هو مؤيد للإرهابيين،
وسأتأكد من أن أطفالي
يعرفون أن جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي جميعهم
إرهابيون، وسيعرف أطفالي ماذا
فلسطين ومن هم الفلسطينيون وماذا فعل
الإسرائيليون
بهم، سيعرف أطفالي وسيعرف أحفادي،
وسوف أتأكد من أن يتم
تمريرها عبر جميع
أجيالي، تمامًا كما سيعرف الكثير منا
أن الصهيونية  هي
طائفة وأن اليهودية والصهيونية
ليسا نفس الشيء، وإذا كنت
معاديًا للصهيونية فأنت لست
معاديًا للسامية، فيمكننا جميعًا أن نعترف بأن
أنظمة مدارسنا قامت
بعمل سيئ حقًا في تثقيفنا حول الأشياء
المهمة و  أستطيع أن أعترف بأنني كنت
جاهلاً للغاية بالكثير من الأشياء
التي تحدث في العالم والتي
كانت تحدث بسبب قلة
المعرفة ولكن الآن بعد أن عرفت لا أستطيع أن
أجهل وسوف أتأكد من الباقي
من حياتي التي يعرفها الجميع